i just gotta lean into this [ __ ] it's
tough man it's a lot of work no one
asked your opinion on this man
didn't you
hey look it's the best hats we've ever
designed they're on sale right now at
quarterdigital.com
store
do you ever have those dreams where you
show up to school or work you have any
clothes on you're really embarrassed
everybody's laughing at you and you just
wake up in a cold sweat well
tomorrow that dream becomes a reality
for jake he's going to have to show up
and perform and be a producer in his
underwear
all right welcome to the studio today
i'm working on becoming a zombie matador
i'm going to be bullfighting a zombie
who's going to be played by brett driver
be a ton of fun now the problem is i
don't know anything about being a
matador so i'm going to have to try out
some poses and then in addition to that
i'm going to be doing all of this in my
underwear the character gets dragged out
of bed now he doesn't have shoes on so i
need to i need to somehow fake wearing
socks making it look like i don't have
shoes on and the only way to do that i
think is to make like a pad for my feet
so i've got this crafty foam here i'm
gonna measure out the size of my foot
and then i'm gonna cut it with the
bandsaw put it on the inside of these
socks and hopefully i'll be able to run
around outside without hurting my feet
i'm jake watson i'll be your host
i mean wow
is that a float or is that a foot that
uh
that works pretty
oh god well it well you think i'm scared
of a little hairs getting ripped out of
my toes i honestly could have bought
flip-flops and you know what danny
no one asked your opinion on this man
didn't you
[Music]
i mean i'm just kind of liberating
myself you know i just put foam on the
bottom of it
i just figured we live in such a uh a
shoe-bound world you know
[Music]
they believed it what's up everybody i'm
christian i am the business manager here
at corridor digital and i will be
producing the zombie video we are
putting together that video will be
sponsored by the walking dead mobile
game we actually did a sam and nico
promotion for them a few months back if
you remember we did a little bit with
nick and carmichael acting as negan and
they came back and they said we want
something with the corridor flare the
quarter style bigger scale so
it might be janky but at least it's
planed the boys pulled me in to work on
the walking dead spot to build a cage
it'll probably be pvc and wood to keep
it light and transportable and it needs
to have a collapsible front so a
character can pull it and open it up and
the zombie comes out to attack the hero
i got 200 feet of pvc pipe cut at seven
foot lengths the bars of the zombie cage
will be seven feet math
we've textured the edges those are
looking good and we had textured the
bars so i lightly sprayed on them more
matte black and it actually led to an
interesting like bit of like metal still
kind of pokes through
with dry brushing you just want like the
tiniest bit so you put some on your
brush and you're gonna wipe it away it's
and you just lightly
just hit it
as well as you can one design flaw of
this is seal it all the way up you have
to do it from the inside zombie bret for
the final screws will have to drill them
in himself on the inside that's kind of
how it goes lock yourself into your own
prison
[Applause]
you know what for the cut because it's
gonna do the rope pull shot and then
we're gonna cut into it falling with him
have his hands on it it'll probably
already be out of it and falling by the
time we cut where that cuts gonna happen
so that'll look nice here we go
three two
one action
it did it
my work is complete
gosh that lens is dusty in there
now if you are sleepish
don't watch this
in the newest mission impossible trailer
if you haven't heard yet there's a shot
of tom cruise making a leap from one
building together and he breaks his
ankle and they use that shot in the in
the trailer in the film itself and it
makes me proud it makes me hopeful that
it might be a good film
i love stunts and movies i love like
real stunts like having a little thrill
in danger the most respectful thing you
can do for a stuntman is if they take a
hit in a shot you use that shot because
that is they they have
given their physical safety for that
shot any time the editor uses the shot
or the actor or the star man actually
hurt themselves doing a stunt that just
speaks to a certain level of
authenticity like jackie chan broke his
ankle jumping well jackie chan's broken
a lot of things
he broke his ankle jumping onto a
hovercraft from a bridge and then you of
course use that shot in the movie like
in a terminator 2 there's like when the
guy gets pulled out of the truck while
it's driving um by the t-1000 and his
head smacks on the pavement but he was
okay
but
you know james cameron had to do it one
more time but they used a shot where he
ended up smacking his head on the
pavement i was like good aragon kicking
the helmet and breaking his toe that's
another good one
it was actually in back to the future
too with one of the stunts where they
had to fly through uh some windows like
hoverboards so they switched up
everything after doing rehearsals at the
last second and this this one woman
wasn't comfortable with it they did it
anyway this is a good lesson if you're
uncomfortable with something don't do it
at the end of the day the buck stops
with you so they're on wires and there's
at one point they get launched forward
and they hit a release and they throw
them through windows and they fall
through under these pads well the stunt
woman didn't actually make it through
the window and the guy who was observing
wasn't in the right spot to observe and
hits the release button without
verifying that all four stuntmen are in
the clear and she gets strapped about 20
feet on the concrete
here they go
there they're on wires
and so they're supposed to fly through
the glass here
and she bounces off the pillar and it
slows her down so they go through the
glass
these are multiple cameras right yeah
this is one stunt with multiple cameras
so they go through the glass that's just
a guy doing a little hit there
and you can actually see her just
starting to fall into frame
um
and there's all pads on the inside so
there she is
boom onto the concrete point but because
she hit that pillar she didn't make it
through there to where the pads are and
the guy irresponsibly hits the release
and down she goes right into the
concrete smack
it's no good but
they use the shot
because if you're gonna do a stunt use
the shot
this is the internet edge lord's hat in
my opinion because you're in the
high-tech stuff but you're also like in
touch with your own mortality it's
really deep
um also
if you don't get that it just looks cool
i know you already saw that hat push but
here's another one this is the first
non-corridor digital piece of
merchandise we've ever sold doesn't have
our logo on it it doesn't have anything
it's just a sweet design and i think
it's special because you know each time
we design something it's something that
ideally we would like to wear as well
you know something that's cool actual
like art you know trying to create a
little bit of art for your everyday life
we finally hit it with this hat this
little vr skull guy here designed by
jack bomb rotary by gabe we have it in
two two styles here i think it's pretty
it's this is the this is the first
hat that's like actually
really cool if you like the hat and hate
what we do it's fine just check out
quarterdigital.com
store you can snag one there right now
these are limited edition
so get them while they last
jake has become a much better actor
throughout all the years tomorrow he's
going to have to do a performance where
there'll be you know 15 crew members
standing around he's gonna have to be in
his tidy white he's on set running
around doing stunts remembering his
lines and doing a full-on performance
and sometimes people freeze up in that
situation for
very obvious reasons
you know it's tough man i was doing the
stances and stuff yesterday and like the
hops
it's tough man
it's a lot of work you're gonna see more
of me today
than you ever have
and more since gta v gta in real life
step into my office
all right
[Music]
let's do this eliza just know that i
when i did this i was focused on the art
i'm not just gonna hide in here and wait
for my scene dude i just gotta i just
gotta lean into this [ __ ] when i was a
kid
i got i had psoriasis and i used to get
it on my eyes people used to make fun of
me and it was like one of those things
where once i figured out i was just like
oh dude i'm totally just gonna lean into
this
and then
it will be totally easier it's just like
dry skin just looked like my eyes were
like red and crusty and how did you how
did you lean into it i just said yeah
they are and then i'd be like you want
to touch them
you know and then they'd be like gross
weirdo what's wrong with you
you know yeah
but that was a lot that was a lot of an
easier way to deal with it than being
like don't make fun of me which would
encourage them to do more yeah so when
you're running around your underwear you
don't like try to hide you don't try to
hide to the world that you're in your
underwear you just [ __ ] get out there
you know
you you just [ __ ] go for it
[Music]
that was so inspirational thanks man uh
i detected no shame or embarrassment
whatsoever which maybe isn't the best
thing in the world
it was great it was great he nailed the
character he nailed the beats did all
the acting great we had no wardrobe
malfunctions
there was no wardrobe jake's a very good
physical actor ever since we shot our
very first short together which is
frozen crossing he's always been able to
use his body language to
express a scene really well and this see
this scene not only required him to do a
lot of matador style work but to do so
in this in the vein of this one
character who is figuring it out on the
spot and more or less being a
pretentious smug douchebag in the
process
don't know how he prepared for it i
should ask him how he prepared for this
scene brett is one of my favorite actors
to work with he is incredibly dedicated
to his craft but we're going to test how
dedicated he is by putting him into
intense zombie makeup and i've never
worked with him in that capacity the
thing is we only have one day to shoot
this and it's taking longer than
expected to get him ready we have some
really complicated fight scenes to shoot
not a lot of time to do it and this is a
man who's never been no this is a son
who has never been in full zombie makeup
before so let's see what happens
subscribe to find out